Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Cutters again, answering important questions that people have
That we hear all the time. Here's a question. What's the process to get started?
Well, really the first thing you're gonna do is look at our site see if this is what you
Really feel led to go down this pathway with us. See if we're the right people for you
I tell everybody the most important thing for me is that your obedient to God
Whether that's to start with us or to start with somebody else. That's fine
Our information that we have on this site is most of it is free. I mean everything on this site is free
Please download my books utilize that information. We see ourselves as a ministry first
So we want to help everybody that we possibly can we can't see everybody possibly so anytime I learned information
I try to make a video or do another blog post or try to teach people something write a new book
That's just who I am. That's how God made me
Understand not everybody is led to come this pathway. Maybe they're just led to learn some things from us
So this is a stepping stone. We want you to pray about your decision
That's the first step the next step if you decide to move forward doesn't mean you're committing to anything
But the first step then is a call call the clinic
Give us a call. You'll talk to one of our staff. We're here Monday through Friday
Leave a message if it's late Friday afternoon or over the weekend. We'll get back to you
Fill out that inquiry at our website
The pops up on the pages fill that out put some detail in there. We'll get back to you as soon as we can
We'll give you information. We'll email you information different pages that you should look at you should look at
Our plans and fees. We have level one and level two on our site
We we are completely transparent with our fee schedule
So we also have level three four five and six. That's not on our site
So if level two and level one, it's like oh my gosh
I can't afford this that doesn't mean you shouldn't call us
We have lower level plans that you could just work with us nutritionally or work with one of my nutritionists to give you some direction
That is very inexpensive just the cost of the nutrition. So we'll help everyone that we possibly can
So don't to be discouraged about the fees
But you should know the fees before you even take the next step and you should also understand what we offer. We're not off-raid
you know
Key more therapy. We're not off-raid IV therapies. We're very specific. We're offering specific nutritional guidance
Specific herbal guidance. We're testing through a cheek swab or testing genetics
We're doing full genetic work up on all our patients. We're testing for frequencies for rife machine
Almost all of our patients get a rife machine. We're testing for drivers of the cancer, causes of the cancer, trying to balance that out
That's what our promises. We have to stay in our lane. What God has called us to do and so you need to understand that
So if you're looking for a chemotherapy or IPT therapy or some invasive type of therapy
That's not what our clinic offers. So do examine our site to see what God has let us to do
The next step with that call is to schedule a case review with me a case review with me will be
You'll complete the online intake form. You'll see you could see that at the beginning here page
It could be either over a zoom or over a phone call all of our work as distance work
So it'll be over a phone call or zoom with me. You'll talk to me
We'll discuss anything you need. We'll discuss, you know
What's going on with your case? I will be very honest with you whether we could even take your case or not
Whether this is the best fit ultimately, you know, it's our decision together what how we want to move forward
So we'll go over that together. I'll make my recommendations if this is something that you can't afford
I'll make recommendations on how to get started with maybe some nutrition
We'll try to help everyone we possibly can that's about a 30 minute call with me and we'll do as much as we kid over that time
Period the next if you decide to move to the next step is to schedule a time with onboarding Angie and Erin are
onboarding specialists you'll talk to them. They'll go over the plans the different levels of plans that we talked about you and I
They'll go over that level of plan that you feel most comfortable with and they'll send you online documents for that
That you can sign online and decide if you decide to move forward again
We want you to be praying through these decisions if you do decide to move forward the next step is we will send you collection kits
For the cheek swab and the saliva sometimes understand sometimes I'll do a case review and then three months later the person decides to move forward
That's okay. It's all within the timing that God is leading you
Sometimes people are like I need to hurry really fast
I looked at your website completely how fast can I get going?
Well, if you make a decision even the same day we do a case review if you're able to talk to Angie or Erin
And you move forward with the documents and everything we can overnight the cheek swab and the saliva collection kit to you and you can overnight it back to us
Um and once you return it to us you have to give us at least five days
Usually we can get it done in three to five days
We could get all the testing done and from the testing we're programming your right
We're testing for what we think are the cause and causes and how we're going to rebalance that
We're testing for what we think are the specific best nutraceuticals for you
Then we're testing for diet and what could be feeding the cancer and fueling the cancer and what we need to
Not have you be eating and then again like I said we're testing for specific frequencies and how we're going to program that rife
And then we send you that rife and the binder and again we could overnight that to you
This can move along quite quickly
We just don't want you to make rash decisions without you praying about it
But if God has leading you this direction we can move about quite quickly
We can overnight the rife to you
Comes in a big box you open it up on the rife computer
We actually place multiple videos and how to get started
Quite honestly, it's pretty easy to use
So most people do not even have to call us and say how do I run this?
They watch the how to get started with the rife video and they're up and running that day
And then they call and schedule a binder review with your liaison remember everybody's going to be assigned on liaison when you start with us
That liaison is your first go-to person that you could communicate with you can schedule visits with her
And you will have weekly visits with her to begin with for the first month
And then after that will be monthly visits with her and then you can email her questions that
She'll forward to Michelle and I to go over on the zoom call
We have weekly group zoom calls so the weekly group zoom calls you can jump on and ask questions
Believe me if you
Feel like you're doing this alone when you start with us to be honest with you
It's your fault because we're here all the time
You could schedule with Michelle or myself you could schedule with your liaison
You could jump on those weekly zoom calls you could ask questions on those you could email
Questions to your liaison which they will forward to Michelle and I and we could go over those on the zoom call as well
And soon we'll have a back office that you can jump on that's going to be privileged information for just our patients
So we want your success. We really do that's what we're here for this is truly a ministry to us
You will never meet a more
committed group of
People all my staff for the bottom of my heart
God sent them to me
That's all I can say to describe them because they are just a gift
To me to our patients. They see this as a ministry and that's how we operate as best as we possibly can
Know that we'll be praying for you whether you choose to go down this path or whether you start and God puts the brakes on for whatever reason
He is sovereign. We want you again to be obedient to him first
But understand we're here for you and regardless of your choice we will be praying for you